wie ist dass sie was ich sie und zogen
plötzlich seither wandern sie zu
us-hersteller baxter und was dann so wie
ich sie hat das herz zerrissen hatte
sich wirklich speziell also das sagen
hat das gibt mir einfach normal ist die
andere hand und freut sich dass jetzt so
weiß können sind jetzt ja schon lang weg
und macht jetzt mit dem vorschlag
verlange aber es sind ja nicht ab
was wenn die eltern plötzlich ans andere
ende der welt ziehen
darum geht es in diesem film
[Musik]
nach 40 jahren in der schweiz ist zum
tor zurück in seiner heimat vietnam
zusammen mit seiner frau sissi
[Musik]
hahn war elf jahre alt als in einer
amerikanischen autobombe
lebensgefährlich verletzte und zum
weißen machte
[Musik]
durch glückliche umstände landete er in
der schweiz wurde medizinisch versorgt
fand eine pflegefamilie und bekam
bildung sein jugendfreund in mit dem er
gerade spielte aus japan bombe einschlug
hatte weniger glück den blieb zeitlebens
hier und ist heute internierte ich habe
das gefühl dass ich schon glück haben
die möglichkeit die nach europa co
michaela mich operieren und der bildung
müsse und könne mit der hand ab ich
mache zurzeit mit das genau gleiche
laboriert also nicht viel können auch
gefährlich an der hütte oder schweine
goethe und zudem habe sie nicht
glücklich und dankbar die höhe
isidor aufgewachsen in meilen am
zürichsee ging mit als sich ihr mann mit
50 seine pensionskasse auszahlen ließ um
nach vietnam zurückzukehren
hier gehöre er hin hatte er ein leben
lang gedacht und sie habe gedacht sie
gehöre ein leben lang an seine seite für
ihn war sie sogar bereit ihre kinder und
enkel in der schweiz zurück zu lassen
gibt es eigentlich irgendwie grund wo
sie würde zurückkehren nichts
die bitte um die zentrale über normal
hans klein um ihren job richtig
die siegprämie mit noir jung zum und
schmecken angeboten was herzlos klingt
ist zu einem guten teil selbst schuld
die wir letzte woche gesehen haben da
hatte sie die frage nach ihren kindern
und enkeln noch an den rand app tränen
gebracht
die wahrheit ist sie bleibt vor allem
aus liebe zu ihrem mann hier
[Musik]
lea toren ist alleinerziehende mutter
und hat ein schwieriges jahr hinter sich
sie ist mit ende 30 noch einmal mutter
geworden und wäre froh gewesen wenn ihre
eltern dagewesen wären wie bei ihren
ersten beiden kindern fini und nun also
das kann sich gar nicht vorstellen dass
wird massiv unterschätzt was große
ältere so leistet und bedeutet und sie
fährt jetzt serienreif gemacht also
offen und neugierig sie sind weiter
große sind wir sehr oft bissig und
sontheim xvi
und die anleger gern kann sich wirklich
super dass ich möchte mir gute mit dem
besteck für eine abgabe sei alles in
ordnung ist und so dass ich freut hand
und ja das ist schön
und jetzt fällt also ich habe mir das
nicht und ich bin traurig dass ich in
die hand und umgekehrt
fini war sechs als ihre großeltern
auswanderte heute ist sie 14
ihr bruder nino ist inzwischen zu bei
mir sehr viel bedeutet und sich sehr
schlecht gegangen sind
was heißt das alles spielt brühe dann
ist er bezieht das weiß ich kann ich
mich was natürlich sehr schlimm wunder
hat jetzt mal ein gespann mit dem brett
es ist so dass sie verliert nemeth das
sterben vielleicht ohne es jemals also
ohne dass wir klären das macht mich
traurig will ich konnte gute fee zu den
beiden kann und ich kann sie also nicht
passt
während wenig kontakt jetzt wissen alle
schon vietnam sie würde ich das mal
interessieren wie die großen trabert ja
an sich schon mal schwer bis 14
ästhetisch untersagt so dass sie viel im
garten machen dass sie hören sind und
dass sie so dass die hinz ich mal
präsent und 11 august ist ein job
[Musik]
der gelernte gärtner sondern hatte
gehofft sich seinen lebensunterhalt in
vietnam mit dem anbau von gemüse und
früchten zu verdienen
nennenswerten gewinn sind seine flächen
jedoch viel zu klein
also liter von seinem pensionskassengeld
die krankenkasse kann man sich nicht
mehr leisten geschweige denn seine
kinder und enkel in der schweiz zu
besuchen sind nie abgelöst
doch viele filme resigniert aber völlig
egal wo ich zeige dass jahr erfolgen
ich zeige dass ihre eigenen beiden
rostock ich brauche ich irre mich riesig
ist die wenn man sie das zeigen ja
einfach an allem an davos glauben wenn
man das zeige
es gibt sehr viele lügen
ich glaube das ist zum beispiel der
botschaft auf der vietnamesischen
botschaft ist nicht damit gerechnet dass
mit der auswahl an der mission
hypervisor sie gerade stehen
ich kann ihnen gar nicht dabei hat mich
ihr euch also ich sehe das mit einem
extra zeigt es nicht so ist
franck muss den mut bewies aber da war
es ist dann nachher was morgen geschieht
zwar optimismus also sag ja
kommt dazu dass er in der schweiz mit 58
wieder eine stelle als gärtner suchen
müsste und nach der pensionierung wäre
er auf ergänzungsleistungen angewiesen
weil bereits mehr als die hälfte seiner
zweiten säule aufgebraucht ist
dabei hatte alles so vielversprechend
angefangen als eine art verlorener sohn
war zusammen mit seiner frau und den
schoß der großfamilie und zurückgekehrt
der referent jahren geld aus der schweiz
überwiesen hatte
er hat fast nur noch kontakt mit einer
cousine ist eine familie in der schweiz
hatte verlassen
aber hier keine neue gefunden mit seinen
geschwistern und den meisten anderen
verwandten hat er sich zerstritten
[Musik]
ja da sind zum teil typische getreten
der große erwarte ich dass man als lang
vietnamese viel gaal bringt er alle
unterstützt und und und und und das kann
man nicht um weil man hört oder also mit
denen fehle aber noch eine tour durch
oder irgend weil ich vor schluss als es
sich hier nur viereinhalb aufhielt und
wieder ging um in der schweiz geld zu
verdienen war es einen verwandten lieber
[Musik]
mira wang war anfang 20 als ihre eltern
auswanderten
sie ist
sie war schon wiederholt in vietnam
ihr freund bruder landtag noch nie wie
ich das für mich ja ich vermisse sie
extrem die situation war nur meistern
es gibt ja schwierig zu sagen wann am
meisten es gibt einfach viele
situationen aber nicht mehr wünscht das
sieht arbeitet einfach zum damit sich
selbst wie es bei mir läuft oder etwas
was ich mir aber gerade abgeraten
aber was für mich und ich bin ich ja
aber das machen
wenn sie nicht krank oder sich nahezu
bleiben indem man auch tägliches teil
dies nicht einfach etwa das sehen wir
noch die ist ein ananas reif sind
[Musik]
das dürfte
da gehst damit eine glückliche wahl
lea ist nicht sondern sleipner tochter
ihre mutter hat sich mit in die ehe
gebracht
und sonst vatergefühle nennt sie das
nicht so im nachhinein gesehen ich für
mich und ich das auch an können selber
reflektieren darüber nachdenke dich du
unglaublich dankbar bin ich immer ich
hätte keine bessere vortrag eine habe
ich bin sehr froh dass er mein vater ist
ja nicht mich zu zeigen biologische
vater
als mutter der kleinen soll wäre ihr die
nähe der eltern wichtig das war nicht
immer so
lea dohrn pubertiert heftig sie wurde
punkerin und lebte in besetzten häusern
was nicht einfach gewesen sein muss für
eben stets korrekten vater der in seinem
gastland nicht auffallen wollte schon
gar nicht negativ
[Musik]
sich das sagen mir sorgen gemacht was
ich noch nicht sagen oder denken
wirklich nicht das thema ob sie habe ich
meine mich sind da nicht so schlimm sie
zu stars des lebens gemacht haben ja
dann nicht die heimat gemacht danach
parameter brauche ja stimmt für hannover
ich glaube dass die csu auf sich selber
das war was du meinst mit voller und
alles richtig machen und genau machen
uns so dass weniger groß war müssen die
kampfstarken durchaus schon noch
ja
[Musik]
immer wieder zieht es sondern zu seinen
eltern die er kam konnte von denen ihm
nur spuren der liebe geblieben sind und
zwei grabsteine
spielen sie dass das in einer biss
gefehlt hat im labor eigentlich kann
flecken kein fleck familie k und sophie
tour so viele andere sache nicht so
bewusst mit nicht so fesch ist ja
eigentlich ein akzeptiertes so ist
[Musik]
und wahrscheinlich
die versuche sind ja nie ich habe es
halt und das heißt ja aus den augen aus
dem sinn also im spiel ist jetzt
wirklich keine große rolle mehr und wird
mal dass ich viele unserer jugendlichen
ganz sport und kannst dir
[Musik]
ich bin ich bin alleinerziehend und weiß
nicht ob es wirklich schlimmes passieren
nicht einfach nur im ppvx oder was ich
dann meine bis möglich lebens passiert
[Musik]
sind für mich hinter da sind für mich
und sage mir wirklich da ich verspreche
ich verspreche es hat sich seit und
schön ist
ich merke schon mit dem song telefoniert
dann hatte und lea und das ist so das
ist hinzu und es ist gleich aus so
schnell dazwischen kommt sie hat immer
das machen soll ich das nicht
unterschenkel für mich will dazu heute
soll das neue tablet hat ja ganz offen
jetzt wollen wir aber übrige hochregal
beginnen kann
jetzt geht's los
und das sieht man